avant même les services, les gens ne sont pas
difficiles autour d'accord ouais fleurs trop
basses
ouais pour être juste à la limite est-ce bon
pour nous en compétition ici dialogue tournez à gauche
tournez à droite vous venez de faire la vallée suivante par
télékinésie vers et à l'intérieur de cette valeur
à vous pouvez mais beaucoup  des
charrues sont perdues à remplacer est oui nous
savons que le jupon était faux ce que nous aimons
avoir ces nuages et ces arbres livre peut suppo
ter mais le venir sur le parapet ni ne vo
s inquiétez pas nous pouvons suivre la sortie du pont
uais parce que désapprouver  à quoi d'
être avec nous
ah
Billu sur le ballon avec Dakota
je pense qu'on va aller en cours d'accord ça
pourrais tu poster l'exemple maintenant appliquer le
monde après que tous les bons
différentiels arrivent et peux tu aller
à Paris évidemment le dimanche noir
après billet-doux  plantation ouais de
coco
helicóptero pelican charlie continue comme ça